[Música]
en cambio es cuando algo pasa de un
necesitado a otro estado con diferente
y por lo general hablamos de dos tipos
de carne aquellos que decidimos
conscientemente como quiero cambiar de
trabajo y aquellos que son impuestos en
el exterior o por otras personas
cuando eres tú quien elige cambiar de
trabajo
quiero hablar
y para ello quiero empezar con una
pequeña reflexiones
te ha pasado alguna vez que estás
esperando a que todo el mundo cambie
para ser feliz
el día de tu pareja que se acuerde de
las fechas especiales que te conocimos y
sobre todo que no le dé me gusta la foto
de la persona verdad
[Música]
cada vez que vivimos de esta manera no
solamente está condicionando tu alegría
y felicidad a los demás sino que es
tremendamente frustrante y decepcionante
no tenemos la podemos decirle ante tres
las veces y aquí tú no puedes ser feliz
cambia para que pruebes también no es
justo
que tenemos un problema exterior en
nosotros se despierta malestar
y nuestra mente hace el típico
razonamiento lógico
si esa situación cambia entonces yo ya
voy a sentir bien por tanto cambiar
pero en que ese problema
de ello e incluso un poco más profundo
que eso esos condimentos y esas
situaciones que tiene siempre son
reelecto interior son precisamente las
que te hacen en comportarte de
determinadas maneras y causan el
problema y el conflicto que quieres
resolver
vamos a profundizar en esto
probablemente todos hayan oído alguna
vez que cuando vive una experiencia una
y otra vez se debe a que hemos aprendido
una enseñanza verdad
y siempre pasa lo mismo siempre
todos los hombres y mujeres de lo que
sucede es que tú eres tu cambiar y por
tanto siempre termina sintiendo atraído
atraída por el mismo tipo de personas y
te sigues comportando siempre de la
misma forma lo cual te lleva siempre a
vivir de relaciones puesto cosas y
exactamente cuántos
como comenté hace un momento cuando
tenemos un problema se despiertan los
otros con malestar y una primera
reacción a veces puede ir a excepción de
frustración tristeza todas estas
emociones son totalmente reales pero son
lo que yo llamo la primera reacción
superficial la razón está en que ese
problema despertó algo mucho más
profundo en tu interior lo que yo llamo
el verdadero problema
la interna
es un conflicto que nada tiene que ver
con el exterior o con las demás personas
es algo sólo de ti
contigo mismo contigo misma
y entonces cuando la pareja
está a esa foto la primera reacción la
crisis de celo la discusión la pelea
parte superficial pero si nos permitimos
ser un poco humana en méxico con
nosotros mismos puedes darte cuenta en
ese momento lo que sentís que fue
inseguridad me siento inseguro no
conocía a mi pareja
despierta el problema y yo y como uno
del conocimiento vamos a ver cómo
resolverlo siquiera ahí empiezas a
comportarte desde esas carencias lo que
llamamos los patrones de conducta así
que no me gusta la foto te sientes
inseguro vas a empezar a actuar desde la
inseguridad que tenés que bajasen como
patrón de conducta pero
y por tanto tu pareja se empezará a
sentir mal se va a empezar a dejar de ti
y va a causar más conflictos en tu
relación y tienes todo ese siglo sin fin
respira
una estudiante me consulta apoyo
singular tengo un problema por más que
trata de conseguir trabajo nunca lo
logró
me falta experiencia cuando esta
entrevista qué sucede
[Música]
pero llega el momento en el que me hace
la pregunta
tiene experiencia y hay alguien con
experiencia
puedes darte cuenta que cuando te hacen
esa pregunta empiezas a dudar de ti
mismo como inseguro si el problema de la
falta de experiencia es inseguro así que
tú te ves que no consigues trabajo
porque no tienes experiencia pero él no
lo consigue porque siempre que no eres
lo suficientemente buenos o tienes miedo
a fracasar o cualquiera que sea el
problema en tu interior que se despertó
en ese momento porque si yo hubiese
estado en esa entrevista y me pregunta
él tiene una experiencia mi contestación
hubiese sido no pero todos empezaron
algún trabajo por primera vez y lo que
sí te puedo decir es que soy apasionado
a los trabajadores y que voy a echarle
todas las ganas todo el esfuerzo
necesario para mantener bien trabajado y
eficiente y productivo
si hubiese contestado con esta certeza y
con esta confianza de porque todos
sabemos que capacitar a una persona es
así
pero encontrar a alguien con esta pasión
con esta determinación
mientras de bestias de chico mientras
siga sin resolver esa confianza así que
pasando lo mismo y buscando entrevistas
de trabajo
comprenden así que tenemos un problema
en el exterior ese problema exterior
despierta en nosotros propiamente como
no lo resolvemos actuamos de esa
carencia como un patrón de cambiar la
situación tiene que cambiar en tu vida
los carneros nunca suceden de fuera
hacia adentro siempre siempre tienen que
ser han florecido desde dentro hacia
afuera
entonces la próxima vez que tenga un
conflicto lo primero que tiene que hacer
es la pregunta que debo cambiar
cuál es mi problema
y entonces una vez que lo encontramos es
cuando viene la parte de esto y ahora
que es verdad cómo lo resolvemos bueno
una vez que ya he identificado y me
siento inseguro o no soy suficientemente
bueno necesito atención la negación lo
que sea tienes que comprender que no
eres un pensamiento no es un sistema de
experiencia
un problema que emocional y las
emociones son mucho más densas que tus
pensamientos
es súper sencillo en el rojo
[Música]
porque son dimensiones por tanto tenemos
que aplicar una técnica que vaya a donde
están
entonces se identifica en un problema
interno
no confío en mí
está bien
es suficiente necesitamos informar
necesitamos conectar y sentido en ese
problema así que vamos a hacer un
pequeño ejercicio muy cortito les voy a
invitar a que cierre los ojos por un
momento
y de pensar que uno de los problemas
fortes ha resonado además de confianza
tu inseguridad que sea y en tu mente vas
a pensar sí
no confío
a veces me siento inseguro
y deja de luchar o simplemente se rinde
nate en una respiración profunda para
potente sentirlo sí a veces así él
y aquí
si se dan cuenta nada más que conecta
internos más pequeños una cierta
relajación de aliviar un poco
entre otros motivos porque no estaba
peleando pero sobre todo porque el
pesaje se vivir esa es la palabra así
que felicidades
hasta cuando hacer su primera
integración emocional ahora sin
continuas haciendo este ejercicio por el
tiempo suficiente esa falta de confianza
el problema interno se vaya disolviendo
disolviendo y disolviendo hasta que no
quede nada entonces cuando la frase
confió en mí toma sentido porque es una
experiencia vivida que trata de
convencer - es una absoluta repita
hasta ahora el problema y tirándole cómo
podemos cambiar
pero cuando seamos crecimiento personal
es muy importante que también trabajamos
la parte positiva para no sentir que
siempre mira nuestras cosas malas de
nosotros sino que también el anterior
ejercicio
de nuevo lo anterior
imagina
felicidad
de nuevo respira por son dos regresen
aquí
pudieron conectar con un poco de alegría
aunque fuese por un instante
sí bueno eso es lo que queremos decir
cuando les explicaba la alegría
pero no estás acostumbrado conectados
con ella así que regresar a este
ejercicio también te va a ayudar a
compensar lo negativo pero sentirte en
canarias o cultivo mismo contigo mismo
el ahora que hemos trabajado la parte
negativa y queremos ver la parte
positiva que estamos preparados para
cambiar unas estructuras de nuestra vida
para que la vida no es un camino que
tenemos que seguir que contienda es
porque guarda los sistemas de creencias
atractivos que la vida no es un lienzo
con un conductor que colorear como
cuando éramos niños sino que en realidad
la vida es un lienzo
y la pregunta es qué quieres
que quiere construir
y permite soñar piensa en lo que quieres
hacer en tu vida lo que quiere es
dibujar el tul y en su absoluta libertad
y por un momento imagina que ya es una
realidad ya existe y 7 todas esas
emociones del éxito la satisfacción de
alegría la revista permanece allí si el
estado te haces la pregunta que tengo
que cambiar en mi interior para
conseguirlo
despacito
recuerda que ahí está el volver a
caminar
[Aplausos]
[Música]